the most important mindset you need for
long-term success on YouTube is to just
keep going ironed enough to pay off
$25,000 worth of student loan debt um
within about 6 months after starting our
YouTube channel so you've have a couple
4 million viewed shorts 1.3 million what
have you been learning with YouTube
shorts how often do you create those
what can I do to the thumbnail or to the
title that will make someone want to
like be interested in that video and
click
welcome back to the think media podcast
I'm so excited because in this episode
we're going to be learning from someone
who's getting almost a million views per
month on her YouTube channel really
breaking down her content workflow how
is she producing content gear putting
videos together really coming up with
her brand the furniture flipping teacher
and all of the success she's built up
just in the last few years so that you
could apply that to your channel to get
more views get more subscribers and
ultimately reach more people my guest
today is a former kindergarten teacher
turned Furniture flipping Enthusiast
Lauren Hull thank you so much for coming
to the show yeah thanks so much for
having us I'm excited and so I can't
wait to first start with your story here
because your YouTube channel has started
just in the last couple years right how
did it come about yeah so you know 2020
everybody kind of started get staying at
home um I was a full-time teacher we
were told to stay at home for that time
of covid and so I was and we were
teaching online but I had a lot of
downtime so I started to um redo my
parents' kitchen and I really loved the
before and after I redid their kitchen
table and I started actually turning to
YouTube um for tutorials on how to do
these different things with furniture
and I saw these YouTubers flipping
Furniture to make money and I was like
well I want to do that because I wanted
to pay off my student loan debt um and
so long story short I started flipping
Furniture began to sell it and then my
boyfriend and now business partner um is
a videographer by or and photographer
and did weddings and things like that
and he kind of C we kind of put our
heads together in a lack of a better
term and we ended up starting our
YouTube channel in November of
2020 and just smooth sailing from there
so to be clear you actually kind of
YouTube's so powerful because you
actually went for information on YouTube
first exactly and did you have previous
Furniture flipping experience I did not
no the the most stuff that I had done
was just really taught by my dad he
always taught me like you know you can
fix things up yourself you don't always
have to call somebody you know sometimes
it might get that far but just fixing
things up um on your own the smaller
projects so I always like to do things
with my hands and then the before and
after transformation was what really
hooked me on the furniture and then of
course the profit that you can also make
from the flipping itself so with this is
it shows you the world we're living in
one when circumstances around us are
going bad pandemic lockdown different
things happening not only can you learn
new skills which did you can also find
new cool ways to make money and in a
practical way Furniture flipping which
fast forward to today too it's one of
the things you're inspiring and helping
others with and monetizing in all the
YouTube ways so you did that and then
you started to being just even a few
months in you had a little bit of
experience growing up your dad but you
learned a skill rela in a relatively
short amount of time tapping into
YouTube Y and then you started to teach
the skill and we sometimes tell people
you only got to be like one or two steps
ahead have a few results and then you'll
you can grow into it even more am I
getting your story right correct yeah
and with my background as a teacher it I
really like again put those two things
together and I was like well I'm really
liking just like the basic process like
now I've gotten into more of the unique
um more intricate processes of flipping
or else I mean I might get burnt out
without just with continuing to do the
basics um but just taking those basic
steps and then being able to apply that
to each and every YouTube video which is
what we really did and that was kind of
our angle from the beginning no one was
really truly going into depth there 10
to 15 minute YouTube videos out there
but it wasn't truly step by step I felt
and so I felt there was something
missing there and I was able to bring my
teaching into our YouTube channel so
that's also why it's called Furniture
flipping teacher um because I was still
teaching at the time um so we just kind
of married the two together and even if
I was ever going to stop teaching we
were still able to keep the name because
that's still what we did on the channel
yeah no very interesting and you were
actually able to pay off
$25,000 of student loan debt from
flipping Furniture yep I earned enough
to pay off $25,000 worth of student loan
debt um within about four well about 6
months after starting our you YouTube
channel so gotcha and so really clever
too that was one of my questions was
coming up with a clear brand Furniture
flipping teachers because you're
actually a teacher right and since that
you have stopped teaching correct and
you're able to go full-time on YouTube
yes from just those income streams yep
but yet it's still accurate because now
you're the furniture flipping person I
can learn from and so I don't know if
it's probably not a double on Tandra
maybe it is it it was and then I feel
like it kind of still is because I feel
like I'm still a teacher at heart and
you know people come to our Channel like
it's one of the things what even though
we didn't know what we were going to end
up with with our Channel like we didn't
really ever have to I mean to be honest
we didn't ever know what was going to
come from this like I was still
full-time teaching someone had just said
since I was sharing on my Instagram my
process my personal Instagram someone
was like you should do a YouTube channel
and it all just kind of fell into place
and so again we didn't know what was
going to come from it but we just kept
working hard it kept succeeding and it
kept growing and so we were like maybe
this is you know what we're supposed to
do so that's November 2020 we're
recording this in October of 20123 so
it's really only been two years three
years I think just about almost three
years this next November will be three
years on the channel gotcha so in three
years and now also fast forward to today
you have have a 4200 squ ft storefront
yes yes we just signed in
September um and that's going to be
opening in on November 4th we're going
to be having a grand opening party so
it's got a thousand foot warehouse and
that I'm going to be doing the flips in
and then the 3200 square fet is a com
combination of a showroom and office
office space and some storage so I got a
lot of questions for you of course we're
going to get into YouTube tactics but
it's kind of cool to like almost see
what's been possible because of this
multi-season journey but in a relatively
short time 3 years in you're full-time
doing this you've got the income from
the YouTube channel and those different
monetization strategies we can talk
about those later but was it always your
vision to be kind of entrepreneurial
build a bigger business because now
you're also adding on to that awarehouse
that will help you film mhm but also are
you going to hire employees to run to
sell on the show floor and stuff I mean
what's the vision for this yeah business
expansion personally I was not always an
entrepreneurial Spirit um that does come
from Neiman my business partner um but
the more I like took leaps and risks
like kind of led by him um the more I
feel like I have a heart for the
entrepreneurial and so yes we I mean
right now we're a three-person team we
have a full-time video editor that does
our YouTube videos only and then um us
too and so Neiman does all the video and
then I do all of the furniture and then
Harrison is our editor and so definit we
haven't laid out everything yet um
because we're still pretty new at the
whole storefront thing getting it all
ready for grand opening is our first
goal but we definitely are planning to
to have some
employees um to help us run the store CU
we've still got to continue to make the
content and that's really what we enjoy
but just opening up the storefront I
think is going to allow us to bring our
community together um people are going
to be able to have uh we're going to
host workshops there we're going to um
host contest there and just so many
other things um down the line that we're
really excited to kind of be like a hub
there in in Oma so inspiring okay so 37
million views on the channel 375 videos
over three years to do
that how did you learn the skills of
creating content when you started making
those first videos what where did you
how did you grow the skills to get that
many views well my first video is a
little cringy but that's we all got to
start somewhere and I think honestly
watching your content just push record
is a definitely something that's always
been in the back of my mind just just
get with it or just get on it and do it
and I was the most uncomfortable person
on um the camera I look back and I'm
like wow but I since then I've you know
grown and grown and practiced and
practiced and so can you sorry can you
say yeah I mean just how what how did
you add the skills over your first up to
375 videos thumbnails titles I mean I
think one of your videos has 7 1.7
million views so yeah a lot of people
listening to this want to get those kind
of results I mean what have you learned
on the journey to you know 37 million
views your first video was bad then it
started getting better how are you
Skilling up
consistency um we were doing two videos
a week at the time that we had started I
was still full-time teaching but we were
grinding it out we were like this thing
is kind of growing let's see what we can
continue to do um and also being
authentic through our content um we were
completely transparent through all the
processes that um I was going through
whether it be like a mess up on a piece
of furniture or um or just I mean even
on camera um and then just continuing to
grow as the community that really
motivated us to also just continue to
make that great content and then
thumbnails I mean that just kind of kind
of got into our groove of making
thumbnails that I thought were pleasing
to the eye nowadays I feel like I've
gotten more we've got and more um able
to kind of be like okay like what would
be interesting to the viewer um as
opposed to just like what I think looks
good um kind of putting those two
together and making sure that it's going
to actually be of interest to someone
because I can paint nightstands night
and day and that's not going to be a
video that everyone wants to watch but
what can I do to the thumbnail or to the
title that will make someone want to
like be interested in that video and
click so mostly on the content it's the
two of you sitting down to brainstorm
about upcoming ideas y it's the two of
us for sure um I pretty much stay behind
the camera and then nean pretty much or
in front of the camera nean pretty much
stays behind the camera but we have had
um different projects that we've taken
um to where both of us are in front of
the camera and do different projects
like we had an uh we did an Airbnb
renovation so we just since we've been
able to grow the community they've also
been really interest become really
interested in our lives um even outside
of just the flipping Furniture so we
really enjoy bringing them along um our
our Liv's Journey as well yeah and I
don't know if I've mentioned it yet but
the community is legit with over 246,000
subscribers now talking about workflow
obviously one listeners might be
thinking okay from the start though
you've essentially had a team
because it was your boyfriend yeah from
the from day one yep and he was doing
video and editing so like I mean the
projects take anywhere from 8 to 12
hours and then he's videoing them and
then they take anywhere from 8 to 12
hours to also edit and so about a year
in we were like okay something's got to
give because I'm still full-time
teaching and so whenever I'm not
teaching he's filming and whenever I'm
teaching he's editing so like we're both
doing basically two full-time jobs at
that time so that's when we kind of got
into
um the thought like okay we need an
editor because this is growing too much
and we want to be able to keep up with
our content because we were enjoying it
we were growing and I mean we just
wanted to keep our channel to on to on
that level of projection how long were
you dating before the YouTube channel
started um let's see we started dating
in 2016 so about four years Okay cool so
you had a long-standing relationship
would you recommend people date or get
married for YouTube
no for YouTube no I would not but I mean
if you have a strong relationship I mean
there's been some ups and downs of
course as it is with every relationship
but I feel like this also brings us
closer together because we're literally
working with each other day in and day
out like 24/7 sometimes we need a break
from each other and that's totally fine
cuz I mean usually I feel like spouses
or um people who are dating have that
time apart and we really don't because
we're do doing everything together so
definitely feeling that flow and just
working all that stuff out hey in just a
second we're going to get back into the
episode but if you haven't heard for a
limited time you can get on demand
access to my YouTube strategy class
entirely for free at think
masterclass.com on the class you're
going to learn the one strategy that we
use at think media that is currently
generating over 300,000 views every
single day if you are new to YouTube
this is going to help you start right
and avoid mistakes and if you're already
a pro this is going to help you multiply
your growth and the cool thing is the
class is 100% free and you can watch it
instantly on demand all you got to do is
go to think masterclass.com or just
click the link in the show notes to get
instant access all right let's jump back
into the episode it is very interesting
on this whole Creator economy this
YouTube culture man so many people I
talked to I think I was just talking
with uh do it on a dime Katherine from
do it on a dime and she as the YouTube
business grows it a lot of times gives
the enough financial resource for the
whole family to go all in on it you know
and that presents maybe a new set of
challenges like does the other person
have that passion do they have that
skill set is there that alignment and
then it's it also is New Challenges
where all the blessing of maybe the
growth is I was just talking to my wife
we've been married 18 years years and
she's like with two kids at home running
our business together she's like man I
need a break from you like that was one
of the thing you know and uh so what
have you learned for or any just advice
or experience or even mistakes for
someone listening to this for working
with a partner working with somebody
else
considering um you know going all in
kind of like you are as a couple um in
building essentially a media company on
YouTube I would say continue to work
together day in and day out but when you
feel like you need that time apart it's
okay to take that time apart um I'm a
person that I feel like never maybe
doesn't admit that I need that time
apart but Neiman is a person who will
admit that he needs that time apart and
so we're able to kind of join in that
and be like okay like let's take a day
you know I'm going to go here I'm going
to go here I'm going to stay home and
you're going to go you know to a coffee
shop and work and even just that day um
apart will be fine I'm uh I'm definitely
one that tries to still like say that
that we don't need that but like I do
know that we do need that so I I
definitely say like take that time when
it's apparent that it's necessary if
you're kind of biting at each other's um
next for a few hours or something like
okay like let's let's take a break um
let's come back tomorrow and see like
let's figure it out here but it doesn't
happen too often but when it happens
listen to it have you have you
encountered a business
decision that you did not agree on and
did you find a way to resolve it I feel
like every day we we have business
decisions that we don't agree on I mean
I would make content every single day
for YouTube and then he is one who is
like okay but like let's let's see if we
can like continue to monetize in other
ways and um so we've kind of started
leaning into the online content or the
online courses and so he's like let's
work on the business so that we don't
have to or let's work in the on the
business so that we don't have to
continue working in the business 2447
all the time and I I get it but at the
same time I really love to flip
Furniture as well so I'm like but I just
want to be in the garage doing my
content um but we've kind of we've been
trying to find a Groove like weekly
where we're like okay let's lay at this
calendar let's figure out like when
we're going to be working on the
business versus when we're going to be
working in the business um just so that
we don't get burnt out that's super
powerful and of course you know for
listeners someone might be you know
sounds nice you you have a you know a
boyfriend that is an alltime
videographer editor but what is
fascinating and and and so if you're
single and that's the situation you can
still succeed you can still crush on
YouTube you always got to play the hand
your delt but I think there's also uh
something to lean into for our listeners
man I just meet so many couples and
sometimes it's also it has nothing to do
with con for me I was the shooter editor
and the talent and all the different
things but I know my world would fall
apart if it wasn't for my wife being
finances QuickBooks managing all of that
stuff like I just shut down on that
stuff and my life would fall apart I
would also I could bring the money in
the front end and it would leak out the
back in and so man there's something
powerful about being a power couple and
there's something powerful about
potentially partnering up because
YouTube's hard so it's it's to do it
solo I mean if you got to do it solo you
can uh but this whole idea of partnering
is something fascinating that may
Inspire an idea for one of our listeners
U you mentioned
monetization if if we were to put up a
pie chart of how money comes in now
you're doing this full-time what are the
different income streams we've got
YouTube um ad Revenue we've got our
sponsorships uh for our YouTube videos
and sometimes Instagram reels we've got
our affiliate sales and then we've got
our online course and you launched an
online course we did yes we we've
launched one online course uh Furniture
flipping to profits and then we are
we've just finished up um our second
course which is going to be for spraying
furniture for for beginners and um
that's going to be coming out within
this month oober where do you host and
sell those courses on kajabi we do well
we have our own website and then it kind
of leads you to kajabi that's cool and
have you do you find that right now as
you're talking that you have enough of a
team with the three of you to manage
everything or do you feel the need for
more marketing support in regards to the
course or customer service is it all
pretty lean how do you hand how do you
think about those things uh I get
overwhelmed um but I definitely think
that we've we've tried we've dabbled
with some um with some people to help us
out we haven't quite landed on the
perfect fit yet um but what we're kind
of um on the on the verge of getting
next and on our team is someone who can
help us with just blogs with marketing
for our course with just I mean there's
so many different things that we want
one person to be able to do to help us
like just kind of fill in these
different gaps you know if listeners to
the podcast I want to encourage you I
always think about this people say Sean
can anybody succeed on YouTube or like
go full-time on YouTube and my answer to
the question is yes I actually believe
anybody
can however I think that it might be
different than some people think meaning
is everyone going to be Peak Charisma
and be the in front of the camera Talent
not necessarily but if you have a
passion for YouTube there's so many
different skill sets that are needed in
the creater economy you guys are a
perfect example and so someone could be
listening to this they could reach out
to you and be like I'm that person
actually like I've been studying I've
been learning I love to write I actually
happen to know blogs and SEO and I would
love like and boom all of a sudden you
maybe have created a job where you could
work from home um you know get out of
maybe a corporate environment and
there's so like creators are building
the next generation of media companies
and so that's what I mean when I say go
full-time on YouTube of course there's
faceless channels you might be the
talent but maybe you also partner up and
work with we're right now hiring all
kinds of people at workwith think.com um
and there's a lot of growth in this in
the space and I think that everybody
listening to this could find a way to
plug in somehow but of course A lot of
people are also wanting to grow their
main Channel they are probably the
talent and I'm curious what you've
learned you've have a lot of high
performing videos but you're also
posting YouTube shorts you've have a
couple four million viewed shorts short
s 1.3 million what have you been
learning with YouTube shorts how often
do you create those right now we just
basically repurpose our Instagram reels
for YouTube shorts um we do have to
sometimes like shorten them a little bit
because they can only be that 60 seconds
um but what I've learned and what I've
seen over time is honestly that YouTube
shorts for us for our situation hasn't
haven't typically like taken off
immediately it's kind of like been maybe
a week or two or even a month or two or
maybe even a few months and then it's
like oh wait like this project this
short that we posted like several months
ago now has like this many hundreds of
thousands of views and you know we
posted that you know so long ago so I
think it's like okay if it doesn't hit
right away but and then also what I've
been noticing is that a lot of
subscribers have been coming from um
YouTube shorts as well have
you observed if those subscribers go
from short form to long form everyone's
asking asking how do I get shorts
viewers to watch my long form videos um
I haven't really observed that too much
but meaning you don't you're not sure
yeah I'm not sure are you active on
multiple platforms you mentioned
Instagram real so do and sometimes think
about Instagram first and then you edit
the videos to go to YouTube shorts what
is your multiplatform approach yes I
would say our main like main baby is
YouTube for sure cuz that's what we
started on and that's just what we've I
mean earned money from to be honest and
so then I would say that Instagram is
our second um we do try to do reals
occasionally throughout the week um I
don't think that we necessarily have
like a set content calendar for
Instagram um but then whenever we post a
real then we always repurpose it and put
it on Tik Tok and then we put it on
YouTube shorts and then we also have a
Facebook page as well that we repurpose
our YouTube videos shorten them down to
the 3 minute to 5 minute that Facebook
really likes um and then we also have
the reals over there as well and do you
find that worth doing is that the editor
that you hired that's repurposing some
of these videos down we're actually
working with like a separate Media
company to do the Facebook part like a
jelly smack type of a company uh it's
called V media and is it because they
take a split of the ad Revenue yes and
do you get any very good ad Revenue we
pretty decent I mean with we're not
doing work on the page we get pretty
decent because a company like that does
everything for you at a split of the ad
revenue and the nice thing is you don't
even have to think about it correct yes
that is the very nice thing that I'm
like oh we posted a Facebook it's piz in
the eye like some money is better than
no money exactly yeah I mean it's
something that we just put on the back
burner like okay the only thing that we
have to do is like whenever we make a
reel we upload it to like a Google Drive
and then they post it but they are in
charge of making all of the short like
the 3 to 5 minute videos from our long
form content on YouTube very very
interesting you've been through such a
whirlwind in the last three
years if a friend of yours sat down and
said hey this is wild I kind of want to
follow in your footsteps I'm thinking
about starting a YouTube channel I want
to go all in in this I would love to
I've got my own separate it's not
Furniture flipping but I've got this
passion what opportunities do you see
ahead for Content creators right now I
mean I say go for it every single time
that someone like figures out what we do
we have them tell us oh I want to start
a YouTube channel and we always
encourage people like do it if you're
consistent if you're authentic and if
you like put the time into it that you
say that you want to to Really create
and go all in on it like even if if it
doesn't hit within the first month like
we were lucky enough to have that
success I say go for it and if
especially if it's something that you're
passion about like your content that
you're passionate about like why not you
know what interesting I was just talking
to a guy he runs a brewery on Third
Street in
Maryville he formerly worked at a church
in the video department and he's pretty
charismatic personality he's very
outgoing and he's been following me
online and I was like man I think
anybody could lean into YouTube and
learn new skills but if he had a couple
things going for him he had subject
matter expertise because he's been
brewing for a long time he's been
mentored he's built a local spot there's
a lot of people that want to do home
brewing he actually has video editing
expertise because he's used Adobe
Premiere and he's got a background there
and he's social I don't think he' think
of himself maybe as charismatic in like
being a teacher but getting on camera
and I want to ask you about that in a
second I'm like man you start start like
like come on like start a YouTube
channel and I think that of course
you're busy he's running a local
business how was it for you what advice
would you have for somebody that maybe
they were already a teacher but now you
put a camera in front of them and that's
scary how did you get overcome that uh
looking at myself I feel like in the
camera and just being like okay like I'm
not going to do that next time or you
know what can I take out that maybe I
was like um um um um a lot but then
continue to watch myself back and then
also just experience like the I I mean
for me I was a little bit um it was a
little bit easier for me because of who
was behind the camera but I mean it's
even easier if you don't have anybody
behind the camera or if you're not with
anybody because you can just do it again
if you don't feel comfortable with that
first shot but I think that practice is
the only thing that's going to help you
continue to get better and get over that
like that cringiness man that's so good
all right so we have a new segment it's
called repeat after me and I will say a
statement you repeat it after me and
then you finish the statement are you
ready sure if I was starting on YouTube
from zero today the first thing I'd do
is if I was starting on YouTube from
zero today the first thing I would do is
make sure that I have good
audio that's great why is that because
I've watched a couple of videos that I'm
just like I can't get past that part so
I think that good audio is a very
important thing to have um not
necessarily that you even have to have
like the best mic or anything but even
just making sure that there's not like a
ton of background noise and things like
that once you start to succeed on
YouTube the next skill that you need is
once you start to succeed on YouTube the
next thing you need the next skill you
need is to be flexible and to be able to
just like rooll with the punches because
there are so many different things with
YouTube and among other content
platforms that change on The Daily that
just learning all like being a constant
learner is super important what are the
sources of learning for you right now
that you like the most YouTube channels
podcasts or anything else where do you
keep learning and leveling up right now
um I watch think media a lot and then
also I
watch a couple of friends of mine who
are also Furniture flippers or one of
them is a Furniture flipper and one of
them is her manager and it's called the
Cypress Room podcast um they do some fun
podcasts but then they also have like
it's all about like influencing with
integrity and um I think that that is it
just is a really encouraging podcast
that I like to listen to um to just
continue to make sure that I'm like
grounded for my the content that I um
put out there the most important mindset
you need for long-term success on
YouTube is the most important mindset
YouTube is to just keep going I think
the best is yet to come um you're never
going to be where you are today tomorrow
you're always going to continue to grow
whether it's in views or money or just
um your skills behind the camera in
front of the camera how you edit um
whatever your content is just continue
to remember that The Best Is Yet To Come
I love it uh Lauren I appreciate you and
uh it's so inspiring what you've done on
YouTube it's a real story that we hope
our community hears that we're all at
different Paces your growth has been
very rapid um but the opportunity is
real and y'all are doing incredible work
and I'm so grateful you came out to be
on the show if people want to check you
out follow you give a roll call of all
the different places and what you're up
to Lucky for us we're all the same
across all platforms Furniture flipping
teacher @ Furniture flipping Teacher
YouTube Facebook Tik Tok Instagram all
of it so that's where you can find us
appreciate you thank you so much for
having us Sean